is this a ladies outing
he has some Indian you guys don't even
know oh my god this is my whole
childhood every party women in one couch
men on the other there's no sitting
together you guys have kids see how
she's just beating down they are by life
think about how much you guys nag them
probably and you yeah yeah yeah look how
like a little happiness they have in
their lives I didn't ask you guys I just
started talking and then you were like
and then I asked them a direct question
do you guys have kids and one guy goes
yes couldn't even hit the ass he just
ate yeah you're so exhausted from all
the kids running around shut up you know
that you didn't say my husband is happy
you just said I won't let this mother
leave me I know what you're gonna do
because I know Indian women because I'm
married to One You're Gonna yell at him
for not being happy like that's gonna
make him happier hey man I'm sorry I did
this to you but I just had to call it
out that's brown noise right there white
noise and static Brown noise is nagging